So I think a lot about the
idea of the creative process.
What happens to
human consciousness
when he is in a state
of cognitive genesis,
when a new idea
is being birthed.
And we hear a lot of people
use the term "no mind,"
or "Get out of your own way,"
or "The only thing getting
in your way is you."
People talk about getting
into these flow states that
silence the inner critic-- the
lateral prefrontal cortex that
is responsible for self
editing goes dim when you enter
these liminal trance states
of heightened creativity
and manic geometries of
association of thought,
where you decondition
your thinking.
There is a kind of "no
mind" when this happens.
I tell people that making
art as a kind of exorcism.
You have to die and be reborn.
And then, when you are
resurrected, then you're like,
wow, look what I brought back.
Look at my canvas.
This is where I went.
Our painting, our
songs, our stories--
they are maps for where we went.
It's the equivalent of us
dropping little pebbles
behind us as we trail towards
new modalities of thought.
The art is evidence.
The art is what
we brought back--
what we transmuted from
the other dimension
to share with everyone else.
To share with ourselves.
To integrate, right?
To upgrade ourselves.
To expand the parameters of
what is, as far as we can tell.